all right it's no way yes no wait
where'd you grow up where you from um I
grew up in Hawthorne so kind of stuff
part of the way yeah and where do you
live down I live off of Broadway and
59th okay South Central mm-hmm oh and
tell about your childhood yet both your
parents no I didn't have really I didn't
have neither of them I kind of grew up
with Grandma where's mom again mom was
mom was um on drugs and dad was just you
know it wasn't around really and how was
your childhood with your grandmother um
it was um it was an okay childhood up
until about maybe say 13 12 then I
started kind of um rebelling and and and
wanted to be with my mother and stuff
like that and it wasn't possible so I
started rebelling with grandma and kind
of got into into some trouble and and
stuff like that but um yeah probably
about 13 years old is whenever I started
prostituting probably 13 yeah
and that was was a damper on your own no
it was it was first it was on my own and
then they're like oh no you can't be out
here like on your own like that you know
what I mean so of course I had to get a
pimp and how was that experience
um it's dangerous it's very dangerous
I don't really like having to give up my
money but you know you can't be out here
on your own and stuff like that right
now I'm actually I'm pregnant by a rape
so and then you can see my I also you
know sorry no yeah so I mean it's it's a
dangerous lifestyle it's not you know
but you got to feed yourself and you got
to feed your your kids and stuff like
that you know how far along are you in
your pregnancy four months four months
yeah and you're gonna keep the baby I
don't think so I don't think so but I
don't believe in having abortions you
know I mean so I will probably give the
baby up for adoption
yeah yeah you've been arrested before
um yeah I've interested yeah yeah and
you've been doing this since 13 yeah how
do you know I'm 34 34 yeah and you have
any other kids yeah I have two kids are
you raising them know where who's
raising them my 17 year old lives with
her father and my two-year-old is with
her grandmother's dad I mean you heard
dad's grandmother's apologize sorry and
this is a rough it's very rough it's
vile have you had bad things happen to
you yes very bad things yes I've been
I've been cut I've been those you know
I've been raped more than once twice
three four or five times you know I mean
I've just been in places where I just
never thought that I was gonna be able
to get out of you know I mean just by
the grace of because I still do believe
in the Lord you know what I mean so I
guess just having faith with him and
stuff like that you know but it's it's a
very scary scary lifestyle and I'm you
know but does it get you down sometimes
yes are you depressed yes yes it makes
you feel less of a woman
you know does because like you know
you're supposed to like like they say if
you don't respect yourself how you're
gonna you know what I mean but I believe
it's not what you do it's how you do it
you know but it's always you always got
everybody saying something you know what
I mean it's never like it's is
everybody's gonna say something you can
make nobody happy you know I mean or you
can't please nobody you can't you know
so I just I just try to keep my head up
and just know that I'm doing it for the
right reasons
you know right are drugs a part of the
picture for you um yes I just recently
started doing crack cocaine yeah so
that's that's another Desa that's that's
a rough one too yeah yeah it's gonna
make it a struggle isn't it yeah yeah
and it kind of makes you forget it not
forget but at that moment like you're
something that you wouldn't do you know
what I mean ends up being okay and stuff
like that you know I'm saying and I'm
not really too pleased about that part
but I guess it just goes along with what
um you know how did you first but it
makes it easier it makes it easier
yes you would say you know I mean at
that at that moment or whatever is here
to do these things normally wouldn't
yeah and how did you first get
introduced to crank through a trick of
mine a trick of mine like every time you
know to mean like whenever we would do
our business or whatever like that's
what he would like to do you know and
like they say you know you go to a
barber shop you're gonna end up getting
in a haircut you know so that's pretty
much what happened not his fault do not
know you know I mean it's just part of
what goes on like they say you're around
it you're gonna end up doing it you know
yeah do you recall your first time doing
this at 13 yes yes and it's not
something that I like to remember
because my very first time was one of
the times that I was raped you know and
I was left I was left in a desert in
Lancaster California first time doing
this at 13 yeah I'm getting raped and
left in the desert
ohand left in the desert yeah yeah and
that didn't make you think twice um I
mean it did you know I mean but like
like you say you know whenever you kind
of cuz whenever I lived with Grandma I
ended up leaving you know what I mean I
ended up getting on the bus and coming
out here to California but on my own I
was 13 14 years old was your grandmother
in El Paso Texas oh I see yeah so I
ended up coming out here you know
because this is where we're from my
family and everybody so I mean how was I
gonna eat how was I gonna do anything
how was like where was I gonna live
where was I gonna you know what I mean
so I didn't have those answers and
that's the quickest and fastest thing
that I knew what to do you know and I
knew that I could do it how much would
you make in a night as a 13 year old um
where's your girl teenager Oh a good
night probably 500 bucks to 700 bucks a
night and how was it now now it's it's
um a little bit you've got a whole lot
more competition I guess you would say
I'm not as young I'm not maybe it's
pretty anymore you know what I mean so
it's like but I still have my I still
have my clients and stuff like that
burgers this yeah I have my regulars I
try to I try to stay with that now more
than than anything but I'm a good night
a good night like a good night
made up - I've made up to seventeen
eighteen hundred dollars in one night
you know but that's out there like yeah
working it yeah that's ten toes to the
ground as you would say you know but
what do you think I'm most misunderstood
things about this lifestyle thanks work
for people that don't do it people they
just look at it go oh this is terrible
Oh become they say like you know because
you're giving out your body you're
giving your body out you know and
supposedly it's supposed to be something
that's supposed to be sacred and stuff
like that and just because we are out
there doing this doesn't mean we're any
lower any less because let me tell you
what a real person or a real prostitute
you enemy takes care of herself because
this is her job you know so and and and
a lot of and a lot of a lot of people
have their you know oh she's this oh
she's that oh she's the other you know
what I mean and it's we're human beings
also you know I mean just like anybody
any and everybody else's and maybe
somebody hasn't hit that point in their
lifetime where they have no other option
you mean are you gonna fall are you
gonna stand for you know I mean what are
you gonna do and I'm definitely not
gonna depend on nobody you know because
I don't like to be told what to do you
know but let's say you're on your own
now without him yeah yeah what was the
best time you're like the best time of
my life I could say I had a sugar daddy
I guess she would call it you know what
I mean and I really wasn't out there
like that
I was 22 to 27 and he took care of me
very good and and and I had a lot of fun
he took me you know I mean he would take
me out and stuff like that and he would
tell me like I'm not gonna tell you not
to do it you know I mean but I'm gonna
tell you that you don't have to do it
you know and he gave me the choice what
do you want to do you know where where a
lot of men will just be like oh you're
not gonna do that no more or whatever
because I always say okay if you don't
want me to do that then can use
support me like I can support myself
then did he take care of you financially
so you didn't have to do it yeah yeah
and did you continue to do it no you
didn't know uh so that was a nice
arrangement first yeah for you in maybe
for him he was married no he wasn't
married he was just an older man care of
you yeah yeah yeah
and what ended us was he ended up
passing away yeah so that'll put a
wrench in the works yeah you know but um
but he was a very good he was a very
good man he was he was a good man and I
had a lot of fun that was the and and I
had my my my daughter at the time you
know I I got it together to where like
she could come over and it was like a
normal living and everything like that
you know what I mean so I guess that's
why I say also that was a happiest part
time of my life what's been the worst
time the worst time is I guess maybe
right now right now right now is the
worst time because you're pregnant I'm
pregnant I don't know what I don't know
you know I didn't know if I wanted to
keep the baby I didn't like being
pregnant because of how it came about
you know I mean but like I said I don't
believe in kill killing a baby a woman
pregnant with a black eye right it is no
it's it's it's right now is pretty
difficult and I'm by myself
yeah I'm by myself I don't have nobody
you know family I have nobody you know I
mean so like I I turned to the streets
for something you know what I mean and
there's a lot of times where I don't get
what I'm looking for you know and you
been loved before yeah yeah I was in
love with that one man that old man I
ended up falling it took me a long time
you know I mean but I did end up falling
in love with him yeah definitely so and
when he passed away it was probably yeah
it was it still is it still is it's
something that's never I don't think is
ever gonna go away yeah yeah what do you
thinking your childhood if it was if it
could have could have changed would it
would have made a biggest impact in
where you are today um to know just to
be heard you know I mean just to be her
just to just for just for somebody to
say how are you you know but I hate
crying
sorry okay just to just to know that
somebody somebody cared you know just to
know that somebody had a ear because it
wasn't um not that my grandma was a bad
person you know I mean but she always
had believed that like you know children
she well she was yeah she was like like
children are supposed to be how do they
say it heard not our children another
seen and not heard you know and um my
grandma was a very busy woman because
she was taking care of me all on her own
and she was older you know so she did
try to keep it all together but it
wasn't very much there wasn't very much
of like how are you or how was your day
at school today or how are you feeling
or anything like that you know and um
and my gum was very strict she was very
strict so she didn't really understand
how to how to just you know she didn't
take very much time to just sit we don't
have a lot of one-on-one time I guess
you would say I didn't have any kind of
one-on-one time with anybody
I guess that's also why I turned to to
prostituting because a man will tell you
what you want to hear real quick you
know what I mean so that like I guess it
felt good at the moment you know so I
guess that was another reason why
because um some of them do know how to
but they say they get they got that good
talk or whatever you know what I mean
but yeah just despite the fact you're
going through some tough times right now
do you think you're generally a happy
person um not really but I try to be you
know but I try to be I don't try I don't
like negative I don't want to be
negative you know I mean but um no
really and truly you know yeah no uh-uh
how do you think oh your years of doing
this has changed you oh very much so
very much so because something like just
your morals you know
and like how people look at you how
people treat you how you feel about
yourself
things that you've done you know what I
mean I don't regret anything like I
don't I'm not ashamed of anything that
I've done
you know I mean because if I'm doing it
I'm not gonna be if you're ashamed or
something that you're doing then you
shouldn't be doing it you know what I
mean but I just wish that it could have
been different or something you know
because it is it's a lot of on your son
how do you college yourself so forth
your self-worth and you're exactly
perfect perfect work self-worth you do
you feel less you know you feel
definitely less are you being treated
yeah and if yourself you know I could be
my worst what would you call it critic
or what or something like that you know
no I mean I could be very hard on myself
sometimes alone yeah what would you say
to a young girl who's this maybe a young
teenager who's considering doing
something like this no no unless you
absolutely have to unless you absolutely
have to please please please if you hear
somebody hear me when I say this do not
do it do not do it it's not easy it's
not sometimes it's not worth it it
doesn't like they say all money isn't
good money you know I mean and money
will not bring you happiness money does
not bring happiness it just makes it a
little bit easier to live but it will
not bring you happiness and these
streets it's a dog-eat-dog world out
here and men don't give up about women
and especially our you know our category
of women they don't they don't it's not
it's not what they say you know trust
and believe that it's just for that
moment of whatever was going on and
they'll tell you anything that you want
to hear but please if there's any other
option that's that that's possible
please go about that option I don't care
if it's selling drugs you know I mean
excuse me excuse me but don't go to
prostitution it's not it's not it's not
fun it's not easy it's not easy very
dangerous very very dangerous and you
been in prison how many times really
I've never been to prison I've only been
to the County Jail
yeah yeah yeah how many probably six
seven times probably yeah that's pretty
good for most yeah they've done it as
long as you have yeah six seven times
yeah I'm not I try to stay I try to stay
away from the police I don't like going
to jail so you know you work Figueroa
yeah exclusively yeah yeah there's so
many girls out very many I mean our
director that's another thing you know I
mean you got to deal with these women
all day long also a lot of competition
ER you know anyway tons and not just not
just your pimp if you have a pimp or
whatever you mean but if you're out
there on your home it's it's pretty
rough to you because you ain't got
nobody to have you unless you got some
homies or something like that you know
what I mean which that's kind of like my
situation you know I don't have a pimp
but I do have somebody that'll go for me
you know what I mean luckily because men
will try to do all kinds of things you
know I mean and if you don't got
somebody to have your back it's it's
pretty scary and pretty dangerous and
then you know you have you have
different different areas where there's
different gangs and stuff like that you
know I mean and if you don't belong to
their gang or if you're not part of
their you know what I'm saying you can't
be on those those streets right there
and then you got the females that oh
this is my corner this is my street this
is my book this is Mike you know I mean
so you got all day long you've got all
kinds of things that you got to look at
and worry about you know who's doing
this since you were a teenager changed
the way you see men oh definitely
oh yes yes I'm seeing men as oh oh yes
I'm shining armor you oh yeah oh yeah
dog trees yeah yeah definitely
and they're and they run the range from
one of the other in reality but but your
your your lifestyle
attracts them yeah yeah definitely yeah
no it's not it's not that pretty or high
when they're walking down the aisle and
they'd look so you know I mean you know
uh definitely not no and that's why this
career is not cut out for every female
right now it's not it's not first time
everything I thought things better
yeah there was a minute where I'm
just like man I can't do I can't I can't
do this you know I mean but like they
say you know when you're hungry you're
hungry you know and you know and you'll
pretty much do do anything to because
it's not a good feeling to be thirsty
and hungry it's not I've been there I've
been I've been you know mean to to where
and I don't I have a real problem with
begging and asking for something you
know I mean like I gotta do something to
get something in and like I just can't
go up to somebody be like I'm sorry I'm
hungry can I get you know I mean I met
I've never been able to do that I
haven't inside on I wish I could you
know I probably would get some money too
but I just haven't been able to to bring
myself to do it I don't know I guess
because grandma was always on me about
that
you know maybe independent work get your
own stuff don't depend on nobody you
know I mean that way that way you can
make your own our family is very the
women in our family are all Pisces and I
don't know if you know anything about
Pisces but they're controlling you know
I mean and they rule the roost so
grandma was always like don't depend on
no man honey you know you're gonna get
nowhere with no man you know so and um
and I like I like it the way I like it
and so like that's why I make my own
money you know I can't I can't live up
underneath of man tell me what to do all
the time and stuff like that it's the
same thing like with the pimp you know
what I mean and there's less you got to
give your money and everything else in
it and then sometimes they're on some
[ __ ] too and you know I mean so I
was like yeah man I can't do it yeah all
right snow white thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem thank you
good luck with everything
thank you
you